[Music]
reject nation Greg Alba here with lovely
this is Bobby I don't like to say
people's made us know is the way for you
to introduce yourself Casey is here with
us today guys
Casey's channel has recently been
revamped it's now a sketch comedy
channel her and two other blondes what
belongs doing comedy is that a thing
apparently and it is now you guys should
check it out I've said they have two
videos up at right actually and tomorrow
there will be another video going up or
no all right from those pros ever try to
be any video properly promote she has
two videos up there right now another
one going up this week guys I'm telling
you there's some hilarious sketches on
there's a wide variety they're putting a
lot of their hard work and talent into
these sketches so please go over to her
channel subscribe right away it'll be
worth your time I'm subscribe you should
too fair is that good is that good I'm
half genuine on half the things I say on
this channel today we're gonna check out
from friends over at screen junkies
honest trailers Deadpool 2 featuring
Deadpool the last honest trailers for
Deadpool actually had Ryan Reynolds I
wonder if that's what they mean this
time Oh that'd be cool that would be
really sweet I bet his grin is all about
that he's all about it's all about the
marketing man but then again the guy who
does the voice of honest trailers John
Bailey does a great Ryan Reynolds
impression yo Gregory how's it hangin
Dibble here I can't wait to do a
reaction to your reaction of the honest
trailer for Deadpool 2 although if we
are being honest it's not actually an
honest trailer for Deadpool 2 it's
actually a commercial for Deadpool to
SuperDuper cut now on blu-ray and DVD
but you know it is what is as far as
John Bailey is concerned I don't think
his voice is all that epic I mean in a
world where one man talks like this all
the time blue-blue and as far as his
Ryan Reynolds voice goes I mean I've
heard better anyways later Alba don't
forget to hook me up with your cousin
Jessica's phone number just love turn
fantastic for to I was on movie fights
again a couple weeks ago yes yo check
that episode out did I
probably not it's loud enough for you
yeah all right after Deadpool one came
out of nowhere and made everyone lose
their minds
a sequel will rise that's just as good
if not better
making audiences everywhere say this
one's good too there's a price point
yeah but this time it's not a surprise
and it came three weeks after a funeral
[Music]
yeah door hit the brakes cut dead who
know it's Banksy would you like to buy a
painting not what yeah yeah you're right
that's pretty much what we're gonna say
why the [ __ ] are you even doing Deadpool
to listen to your commenters and tear
KOCO a new those are really sweet movie
and Deadpool - isn't alright nuts hit it
blind out honest trailer for honest
trailers nice chugging along
[Laughter]
[Music]
movies are actually been great these
days
well most of them watch boards find one
logic gap and pretend like it ruin the
whole movie
actually if cable changed the future you
wouldn't have to travel back in the
first place
good point no you pedantic horse [ __ ]
it's a movie about a cyborg cartoon with
huge pouches and tiny feet
stop pretending it's the real world they
just say bewbs for no reason to move
away from that market choice Department
they're slower fans keep requesting
trailers for movies that are still in
theaters
unlike Deadpool - super duper cut
available now on digital which actually
isn't bad but my movie did it way better
like half of yours are just bad puns
Gary's knees are Jesus Joe don't talked
about in the same sentence as Jesus
Passion of the Christ
then me Deadpool is the highest-grossing
r-rated movie of all time except for
Jesus that I said on our video I do not
need to be here I could be playing for
tonight with Drake ninja and Mike Pence
right now sorry starring dead horse all
kinds of turgid
we have been nominated for three Emmys
yeah yeah well that's three Emmys oh
come on this is a king outrage
we're done here wait don't go
yeah he'll be back her detective Pikachu
yeah well good more flavor than fruits
right gun oh man this is the purple
Wallace volcano nightclub you and your
absent which is welcome it's so awesome
that he was here for that words super
easy what is it that was a lie yeah you
can keep the headphones on you look
better with a lot like when it blocks
your ears I really like that honest
trailer man it's cool to see them mix it
up with having Ryan Reynolds actually
show up here do an honest trailer for an
honest trailer format I think honest
trailers are harder to do over a comedy
because an honest trailer format is
already supposed to be something funny
so it's like make fun of a comedy is
gonna be a little bit more challenging
the fact that screen jockeys is also
willing to make fun of themselves so
much I'm pretty sure they wrote it now
for him Yeah right I mean Ryan is a
writer though as Deadpool it is such a
Deadpool character thing to flip a the
tone of these is the same tone of
Deadpool so it's like that's why I think
it fits so well that kind of like snarky
you know smart [ __ ] thing I don't
know so like him coming in and like
writing his own rendition of it well I
think he is a fan of honest trailers so
I wouldn't be surprised if he did come
in and write it well I like what they
said oh they were like yeah one person's
gonna take one element of one movie and
make an entire illogical thing out of it
and like people did criticize a lot of
the cable stuff in that movie no way how
some time travel stuff goes down and
whatever for Deadpool himself to be like
guys it's a comic book character about a
time-traveling cyborg
you don't need to read so much into this
you know it's not that heavy it's not
that important like Oh chill out a
little bit even if it's Ryan Reynolds
they're still putting the video together
and making fun of not just put on
trailers is making fun of how some of
the fans are too
requesting to do honest trailers for
movies that have like just come out or
not even out yet in the theaters like
how can they possibly do it honest
trailers for that at that point I mean I
feel like there was a couple of times
where they had early access to it but I
feel like they they have to you know to
get all this footage and stuff to make
it well work
oh I understand now it makes no you
can't disease it sure you got to use
like spoiler scenes and stuff because
these things are usually contain
spoilers so yeah I don't know why I
never thought of that it's okay it's
okay
you can catch that really in mine over
at blonde jokes channel people get in
the me tube movement a good and he's
making fun of the puns that they deal
with the names
I love the puns though screen junkies I
love every pun they ever make you're so
funny
Carlie I love a good fun I love a good
pun you gotta get puns the upon master
no I'm not I roll at puns
I got what nah man he returned a clapper
in the crab but even though I really
like this honest trailer and I like that
Deadpool was doing a spin on it and like
Ryan Reynolds having him involved I do
feel like Deadpool too more than
Deadpool one opens itself up to have an
actual honest trailer though oh yeah and
I feel like there was plenty that they
could have criticized there's plenty
that they like I've seen the review on
the movie - I kind of wish we got an
actual honest trailer as well
maybe if they did like an actual honest
trailer and then the Deadpool portion
because this is only three and a half
minutes so maybe if you did like a
two-minute version of it I probably
would have liked that but that's just me
being an unreasonable screen junkies fan
of wanting you writers and editors - the
two more artwork and to make me happy
for a couple minutes
long cuz how long are they usually
usually like 4 to 5 minutes their last
one infinity war was like six but that's
infinity right and there was a lot to
talk about that yeah yeah got it so you
think that because Ryan came out on this
one they cut their criticism short I
know they usually don't like to do
honest trailers for actual comedy movies
but I still feel like there was plenty
here that they could have deconstructed
in their honest trailer format that
could have made for like a good worth
while honest yeah they could have talked
about a lot I say I feel like they could
have done an actual honest trailer and
then they could have put the Ryan
Reynolds version on it afterwards that
was making fun of what they just pointed
out like Oh honing in on this thing they
could have made fun of the cable stuff
and then Ryan Reynolds gonna made that
joke about cable that he made here you
know this little tip for you Emmy
award-nominated writers you know I just
don't hope you guys web media I forget I
don't know Sally's yeah yeah watching
their videos yeah this one is totally
because we wrote all this out all the
dialogue it sounds like we're
improvising and just speaking up it
needs out like candy
yeah what's downgrade there Emmy
nomination nominate the channel for an
Emmy I don't know don't waste your time
guys hey you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell more
importantly check out Casey Spivey on
the blonde jokes Channel we're just
typing Casey Spivey there's a link in
the description box there's an end
screen here there's a pin comment
there's a bunch of plate that you can
slide it go check it out yeah yeah